we're gonna do the egg test I don't
wanna risk crushing an egg all over my
hand and mattress and sheets and
everything so I kind of split the
difference pushing down on the egg it's
all the way down okay we're going to be
using purple products for a week to see
if it helps our sleeping problems I have
a little bit of sleep trouble I have
lots of like old like basketball
injuries and stuff I've broken both my
ankles before seven years ago actually
fell through a trap door and I caught my
arm on the stairs basically have
whiplash and pinched nerve in my neck
like my back will hurt and my neck hurt
and I wake up a lot and I just I'm achy
so the first thing is when you actually
get the mattress
it weighs a million pounds it's so much
heavier than it looks when you get it
actually on the bed it's like in this
pool like shrink wrap it's growing it's
so weird the pillow is very comfortable
it also weighs 40 pounds and is made of
materials that you would never expect to
see in a pillow what is this this is so
trippy so weird Oh God oh I am sweating
oh my god pillow feels like a but if it
feels like a but so it feels like you're
just napping on someone's butt last
night I tried to go to bed at 9 o'clock
and it worked my back feels better than
it normally does I did wake up a few
times during the night
but nothing too crazy first many had a
really bad it's just like getting your
stable and I think it was also about 212
they came with these pads that made it
taller and thicker and the first night I
realized I didn't like that so I took
those out and it was much more
comfortable it was like perfect for my
neck part of his video should be that we
get to stay home and be on the bed all
day
that's test when I did open it
mine had like powdery stuff inside like
I think just from the rubber a little
bit like when they cut it or something
there's kind like a natural like I don't
know what it was it wasn't a big deal
but it was like kind of weird and then
after that I was kind of like every time
the air like whooshed out if there was
like you kind of like smell the rubber a
little bit and I was like my inhalant
away powder this morning and my hip is
pretty sore so I kind of hoped that the
purple would make more of a difference
on that but seems like maybe that's just
unavoidable there's pillow since it was
so like if he for me I just used it as
kind of like a pillow that would
accompany my current pillow I just like
switch back and forth it wasn't like a
miracle cure like I would still have
some back soreness in the mornings or if
I slept on my wrong side then I would
have a hip pain a little bit but it
drastically reduced how many times I
woke up during the night I mean this
could also be my anti-anxiety medicine
it also felt like a lot less anxious it
like creates a space where I could just
really just relax
[Music]